I like motion I gave you yes there to
sort of ways to define it right to my
sty understand it
the second wave is sort of more
technical way but there's a little hard
to understand if you just get the
equation on its own but I want to come
back to it so there's some how do you
convey these differential equations and
I said differential equations plural
because you've actually met one of these
before
in the last topic we do okay so do you
remember we start out in particular
situations right the natural growth
growth decay they follow this particular
differential equation I just didn't call
it that things like this on DT okay is
equal to K P right or minus P now what
is this again there's your first three
okay and there's your original function
and the relationship between them is
that they're proportional to each other
okay
now the way we are taught about this was
what kind of function what kind of
family of functions fits this kind of
district description when you take a
function you differentiate essentially
you get the same thing back the only
difference is the scale or the constant
out the front okay and we said okay we
know exactly what this looks like this
is an exponential function right things
like this right and when you
differentiate chain rule brings that K
at the front and there's your
differential equation okay so therefore
we're thinking about this this is the
equation I gave you yesterday X double
dot is equal to it - n
X okay can you see the parallels between
them okay instead of page we've got X's
here because that's our custom way to
indicate displacement but really see
deal right second room in there another
cluster at the front and there's your
original function
excuse me now in just the same way we
looked at before right we said what kind
of function do we know that behaves like
this when you differentiate it you get
the same thing math okay so the question
is right sorry that shouldn't be a fee
this isn't it what kind of function if
we differentiate it twice Jesus back
basically the same kind of function the
answer is a trig function which seizes
before right so I'm going to give us
this kind of definition a simple one to
begin with and then we'll expand on
different different lyrical humbug
measures different variations on it
later on o or or cosine it doesn't
matter or n T now let's have a look at
this for a second when you differentiate
this differentiate once and you'll get
velocity so velocity when you free check
with respect to time this is just simple
chain rule right so on the inside here
I've got an T star differentiator get in
and on the outside I've got signs that
turns into
okay now there's velocity to get my
acceleration when I get from here right
I got differentiate again so
acceleration or force right there's
another instance of chain rule so the M
comes out the front again okay so I've
got two lights again
but of course push light doesn't go back
to sign it goes to negative sign right
and now you can see where that minus N
squared comes from yeah all right so
that's why we're going to use these
basic trig functions as the basis for
how we're going to discuss simple
harmonic motion later on we'll introduce
okay what if instead I'll just sine of
NT which is very very simple
it means you start off at the origin
because you substitute T equals zero in
there and you'll get x equals zero we're
going to look at different kinds of
shift so x equals sine of NT plus alpha
and also different kinds of amplitude
right and so things like say a plus sign
should've put in the n plus a so that's
going to change your equilibrium
position your centre of motion okay
we'll move up or down and of course we
can also change the amplitude if we
learn its thinking okay so these kinds
of different versions of this they all
work the same way they still follow
these results because when you
differentiate and you're still going to
get essentially the same thing though
this constable just be a little
different cuz it disappears each time